here are the top three episodes of
Attack on Titan in third place we have
bystander which is a super emotional
episode about the backstory of
instructor shardes with an ending that's
guaranteed to give you goosebumps every
time in second place we have part 3 of
The Final Season which was an hour-long
special that showed the full destruction
of the rumbling and had some cool Easter
eggs as well finally in the number one
spot we have two brothers which is the
episode that literally had everything
you could want we got betrayal suspense
sacrifices original moments and of
course the main character being
decapitated